-Welcome back.
We're talking to our good pal
David Spade right here,
ladies and gentlemen.
He has a new comedy special
called "Nothing Personal."
It's very -- It's hilarious.
You talk about everything.
This is your greatest hits.
-Yeah, some of it, yeah.
I talked about -- One of
the things was click bait
because I got caught into
some click bait once
where someone passed out at
one of my shows, had a seizure.
And then you know how they
switch it to get the headline.
It's like, "David Spade stops
show because of seizure."
So, it sounds like it's me,
you know?
-Yeah.
-So people -- "Oh!"
And so you click on it.
But the ones that really get you
are so obvious,
and I know they are, and they
just take you down a wormhole,
but I click them anyway.
-Like what?
-You know, you're just reading
about like,
"Oh, Cardi B and the draft is
coming up."
Then it goes, "What's the one
vegetable Tom Brady
refuses to eat?" I'm like...
[ Laughter ]
"This is stupid. Who cares?
And then I'm like,
"Is it a coconut?"
[ Laughter ]
And then it gets in my head
and I can't --
and I start to go down.
And it bothers me.
Everything's blurry.
I go, "I got to find out."
So I click on it, and it goes,
"Tom Brady was born
in Northern California."
I go, "Uh-huh."
-Okay.
-"Next."
-Ooh.
-"Tom Brady started playing
football at the age of seven."
I go, "Where's the mother[bleep]
vegetables that you swore to God
you would talk to me about?"
And then 55 clicks later, it's
a tomato, ladies and gentlemen.
-It's a tomato. There you go.
Now we know.
-Spoiler alert. I was way off.
But then they get mean.
It goes, "You'll never guess
what this
'80s actress looks like now."
[ Laughter ]
I'll save you 48 clicks
and 2 1/2 hours.
She looks like [bleep]
-Okay.
-It's so mean. I go, "She aged
30 years in 30 years?
That was her big crime?"
-Yeah, that's what people do.
-Then it goes,
"Look at this lady now."
And it was me.
[ Laughter ]
I go, "That's me,
and I look good now."
And they're like,
"What happened to this guy?"
-Let's talk about
"Nothing Personal."
It's on Netflix.
-Yes.
-What do people need to know
about this special?
-What do they need to
know about it?
I don't know. It's an hour long.
And it's mindless stupidity.
And you'll be hungry for comedy
an hour later.
It doesn't even sink in.
It's nothing important,
I'll tell you that.
It's not like --
You won't walk away like this.
"Huh, I really have a lot
to think about now."
-You leave going like, "I had
a good time. I laughed."
-Yeah. You're like,
"That was dumb, yeah."
-No. It's super fun.
-It was a good time killer.
-I want to show everyone a clip.
-Oh, we have a clip. Ooh!
-Yeah. Here's David Spade
in "Nothing Personal."
Take a look at this.
-I sit down and sometimes
it's such a nice restaurant
that the fish is market price.
You ever seen that?
They don't even tell you
how much it is.
I think the waiter tries to
guess how rich you are.
Because I go,
"How much is the tuna?"
He goes, "Um...
The tuna is...
Bah, bah, bah, la, la, la.
The tuna is...70."
I go, "70 bucks?
He goes, "40, 40, 40."
[ Laughter ]
-David Spade, everybody.
Check out his stand-up special
"Nothing Personal" streaming
right now on Netflix.
-That's the cleanest joke
we could use.